[Música]
5000 millones de personas en el mundo
carecen
de acceso a cirugía segura y asequible
se necesitarían 143 millones de cirugías
para reequilibrar la balanza de las 313
millones de cirugías que suceden en el
mundo solamente 6 % suceden en países de
bajo ingreso o subdesarrollados como les
decíamos antes
y esto es un problema solo de los países
subdesarrollados en los eeuu se gastan 3
billones 3 millones de millones de
dólares al año en gastos en salud y a
pesar de esto 440 mil personas mueren
cada año por errores médicos prevenibles
una de cada cuatro personas que entran
al hospital sufren o salen con una
complicación el cuidado de la salud está
en serios problemas
las causas son muchas y muy complejas
para mí el mayor problema es que hemos
perdido la empatía la humanidad en
medicina
hemos perdido la conexión humana
yo pienso que el estado si no hoy en día
es realmente deplorable es vergonzoso y
es vergonzoso porque en el siglo 21
cuando tenemos tecnologías tan avanzadas
que rayan en la magia
hay seres humanos hermanos y hermanas
terrestres que no tienen acceso a la
salud y la salud es un derecho humano no
lo digo yo lo dijimos todos en el año 48
en parís en la declaración de las
naciones unidas
la salud es un derecho humano toda
persona tiene derecho a un nivel de vida
adecuado que le asegure la salud y el
bienestar y en especial la alimentación
el vestido de la vivienda y la
asistencia médica a pesar de esta
trascendental declaración
la salud se utiliza como una herramienta
política como un argumento económico
especialmente en épocas elecciones
y yo me pregunto por qué
yo quiero pensar
que es por falta de innovación de
creatividad
me entristece pensar
que es por falta de deseo de que mejore
que es porque no nos interesa
no nos da la gana que no nos importa un
carrizo como decimos en venezuela
yo soy cirujano entren en venezuela
estoy en medicina en venezuela se mis
estudios de cirugía en los eeuu
como cirujanos vengo de una larga
tradición de médico en la familia por el
lado materno y abuelo mis abuelos de una
foto de mi bisabuelo el doctor rafael
zamora área de 1897 dando una clase de
anatomía por el lado paterno
mi papá mi tío el primero de nosotros
que llegó a venezuela principio de los
1800 desde alemania este es una foto ya
de viejo una pintura de viejo pero un
muchacho 23 años que después de ser
ciudadano en las guerras napoleónicas
por el ejército de prusia después la
batalla de waterloo se fastidió y se fue
el nuevo mundo llegó a venezuela y se
unió los ejércitos de bolívar
peleando contra los realistas españoles
yo soy la sexta generación
después de un año lo nombraron un
cirujano general de los ejércitos de
angostura los ejércitos libertadores
y como nota interesante a lo largo de
ese tiempo él
inventó un brebaje medicinal que se
transformó después en el famoso
amargo de angostura no sé si lo han
probado y
activo a cualquier bebida y alimentos un
aditivo que lo encuentra en cualquier
bar que se respete en el mundo
yo como le digo
pienso que soy un aventurero un
aventurero porque crecí en venezuela-
paraíso
verdadero paraíso natural
cuando termine mi carrera de médico me
fui a ser mi año rural a una zona
cercana a caracas
a una hora distancia en carro pero a
décadas de distancia en progreso médico
tecnología de comunicación en ese
momento estamos hablando del año 92
olvídense de celulares
y telefonía de texto volviese de la
internet el medio de comunicación más
efectivo era montar al paciente en la
parte de atrás de un jeep y llevarlo al
hospital en caracas más cercanos
eso todavía pasó
yo como medio soy cirujano todo lo que
yo hago en cirugía requiere de muchas
tecnologías tecnologías muy muy
avanzadas yo siempre pienso que soy un
poquito como un kit se acuerdan los
en las películas severas pero
usando otro tipo de lentes diferentes
unos lentes de alta tecnología que nos
permiten comunicarnos y conectarnos
mejor
estos dispositivos comenzaron en mi caso
con google glass un aparato casi que
mágico exponencial
que a pesar de ser de haber sido creado
para entretener
se ha transformado en un instrumento
para conectar lo mejor con los pacientes
con los familiares para educar mejor y
en cierta manera aunque parezca
paradójico mejorar la medicina esto fue
la primera vez cuando yo lo usé en un
quirófano hice un streaming en vivo de
una cirugía y eso despertó muchísimo
interés a nivel mundial esto ayudó de
cierta manera catapultar me a
convertirme en un ávido evangelista de
la tecnología usada inteligentemente
para mejorar cómo hacemos medicina cómo
enseñamos cómo educamos
no sólo medir las hay otros como este el
bus ix que es un instrumento como el
google line esteroides
instrumentos que parecen casi que
mágicos
esto causó como le digo sensación a
nivel mundial y en cierta manera pues
ayudó a establecerme como un comunicador
como un educador en el tema de la
tecnología aumentando lo que hacemos
yo siempre pienso que la tecnología nos
aumenta como humanos es tan importante
que practiquemos una medicina más humana
yo tuve tengo la bendición de tener un
papá que lo da todo por sus pacientes él
y algunos mis maestros me enseñaron la
importancia de la compasión de la
empatía de tocar la puerta en el cuarto
de los pacientes de pedir permiso
sentarse en la cama de verlo a los ojos
de tocarles agarrarle la mano reír de
llorar con ellos
es tan importante como les digo que
practiquemos una medicina más humana la
expresión de gratitud de un paciente
para como uno como médico es una de las
sensaciones de bienestar más profundas y
bonitas que uno puede experimentar la
medicina yo pienso que representa uno de
los más altos valores humanos
la tecnología es parte de nuestra
especie nos define como especies yo
pienso que la tecnología puede rescatar
esa humanidad
es parte de nuestro adn si se quiere
uno de los mayores problemas en medicina
como les dije pienso que es la mala
comunicación y la mala conectividad
entre proveedores de salud y pacientes
es uno de los problemas más graves que
enfrentamos en medicina
la internet la telefonía celular el
incipiente 5g está cambiando el planeta
está cambiando como nos comunicamos está
un ejemplo en china hace pocas semanas
una cirugía robótica realizada en un
animal a distancia a 3 kilómetros de
distancia pero conectado con tecnología
celular de 5 g
unos días después se realizó una cirugía
en un humano en un cerebro a tres mil
kilómetros de distancia de nuevo
utilizando tecnologías 5g
el mayor ancho de banda la imperceptible
latencia hace que esto sea posible
de verdad que estamos evolucionando a
pasos agigantados
todo por el uso inteligente de la
tecnología
no sé si alguno de ustedes habrán visto
un aparato como este el primer teléfono
celular un motorola 3.830 teléfonos
números de teléfonos podríamos albergar
aquí en exceso era una maravilla un kilo
y medio una herramienta que nos asombró
a todos el que carga uno esto era una
persona que todo el mundo pensaba y
quién es ese que tiene un teléfono
encima todo el día
y ahorita estamos con los teléfonos
inteligentes empezando con el iphone 4
que nos permitió con facetime hacer
videollamadas algo que nunca lo habíamos
pensado eso ha revolucionado cómo nos
comunicamos y cómo nos conectamos en
medicina y en educación
hemos de verdad llegado a niveles
exponenciales muy muy lejos sin embargo
la medicina se ha quedado atrás y eso es
vergonzoso
e imperdonable
yo les propongo pensar diferente
retomar nuestro destino el destino de
millones de personas en países menos
afortunados
utilicemos la tecnología para optimizar
el sistema de salud para aliviar el
dolor calmar el sufrimiento para salvar
vidas
para educar mejor a las futuras
generaciones
usemos la para mejorar el acceso global
a la bendición de una medicina segura
asequible
usemos la tecnología para resucitar la
humanidad en medicina
y ahora la magia
quiero hablarles un poquito de la
computación espacial hablamos de la
primera etapa de la computación de la
computación de caracteres caracteres ms
2 la computación de interfaces gráficas
como un macbook con los iconos en el
escritorio la tercera etapa de la
computación de toque que es la que es
tan bonita con las tabletas y los
teléfonos inteligentes y ahora la
computación espacial que nos permite de
cierta manera usar el espacio como
escritorio esto de cierta manera ha
revolucionado cómo hacemos cómo
interactuamos con las imágenes digitales
la realidad virtual inmerso en una
realidad digital de realidad aumentada
donde se crean imágenes digitales
sobrepuestas al mundo real
virtual mixta que es la imagen digital y
la imagen real pero interactuando una
con otra
en medicina esto está causando una
verdadera revolución empezando con el
google cardboard hace unos 5 o 6 años
con el magic clip la última
edición de lentes inteligentes de
realidad mixta de realidad virtual
tecnología es tan avanzadas que son casi
indistinguibles de la magia
estamos de verdad viviendo una verdadera
revolución pero en realidad ha sido la
evolución de los sistemas tecnológicos
desde la época en que las salas de
anatomía lucían así y esto es lo que me
llamó la atención los muertos enseñando
a los vivos muertos y vivos 12 yo
predico los la tecnología enseñando a
los vivos hoy en día eso tiene que ser
el lema en el hall online por ejemplo
podemos tener clases de anatomía en
realidad mixta que nos permite enseñar y
nos permiten aprender mejor sin ninguna
barrera de una manera más accesible
en el teatro quirúrgico los espectadores
aprendiendo cirugía es igual hoy en día
con google glass no puede tener la
perspectiva del cirujano y estar
conectado con el cirujano aprendiendo y
enseñando remotamente rompiendo las
barreras donde los estudiantes no tienen
que estar detrás nosotros tratando de
ver si no pueden estar remotamente
situados pero presentes virtualmente
usando herramientas como el carbón para
conectarse con nosotros no importa donde
estén
y de nuevo exponencialmente mejorar su
enseñanza podemos sumergirnos en una
realidad virtual con la anatomía real
del paciente o podemos sumergir a un
paciente en su propia anatomía para que
entiendan mejor lo que estamos tratando
de explicar como un verdadero viaje
fantástico
si se acuerda del libro de asimov hace
varios años que después una película es
algo fabuloso podemos interactuar con
tecnologías aumentadas de realidad
aumentada para aprender mejor anatomía y
fisiología de una forma que nunca
imaginamos
qué tal si antes de una operación
aprendemos
acerca del paciente a interrogarlo a
examinarlo un paciente virtual un
paciente que nos permite tener acceso a
él en cualquier momento hacer simulación
donde la simulación puede pasar puede
suceder en realidad en virtual pero
también podemos utilizar sistemas
ópticos como este guante que nos
permitan sentir la imagen digital
la simulación es totalmente diferente
hoy en día podemos sentir esa imagen
digital antes de tocar a un paciente
humano disminuyendo las complicaciones y
aumentando nuestro aprendizaje
podemos manipular las imágenes digitales
de una manera nunca antes posible
es en verdad una revolución
inclusive casi que tele portarnos donde
podemos crear hologramas en tiempo real
en tamaño real que se comuniquen con
nosotros y de cierta manera avatares que
tengan inteligencia artificial centrada
en el humano y nos permitan como un chat
bot pero con cara humana conversar con
nosotros aclarar nuestras dudas cuando
el ser humano la persona de carne y
hueso no esté presente
la tecnología de verdad nos ayuda pero
solo si la usamos inteligentemente nos
permite rescatar nuestra humanidad
si conocen este juego tictac tau la
vieja gato cuando una computadora juega
esto rápidamente determina que la única
estrategia para ganar es no jugar pues
en relación a la medicina y a la
inteligencia artificial
la tecnología el no jugar no es una
alternativa
a aquellos que dudan
se preguntan si las máquinas van a
sustituir a los médicos
yo les aclaro los únicos profesionales
en salud que van a ser sustituidos son
aquellos quienes no practiquen la
compasión
a aquellos que no se adapten
profunda emocional e inteligentemente a
este tecnológico maravilloso y mágico
nuevo mundo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]